it was the blue sky. New directions to follow without thinking. Let's see, children, who among
you can tell me when America was discovered and who discovered it? It was Columbus. If it wasn't
Columbus, then who was it? I understand why you say that, but what none of you have any idea how
to think? It was the Vikings. The Vikings. You could say it was the Vikings, but to understand
that we have to go back in time. I said go back in time. Stop. That's good. Our story begins with
Norwegian with a terrible reputation. Eric the Red, a Viking. Do you know, children,
that in the 9th and 11th centuries the Vikings spread terror across Europe? From Iceland and
Scandinavia across the seas and sailing the great rivers along Russia and beyond Morocco.
These adventurers could trade or plunder as the circumstances dictated. If anyone fought them
they learned how powerful they were. But the eastern side of Iceland was completely unknown.
This is where our adventure begins. The story of an unlikely family.
Listen up. In the year 964, Erik the Red was banished from Norway for murder and went to
Iceland. But when he got there, Iceland was overcrowded. Food was scarce. Once again his
fiery nature got him into trouble. In the year 982, the Icelandic court met to try him. Once
again he was banished and Erik the Red set sail, heading west. The wind is fair, Erik, but it's
getting colder. Where are we headed? Have you heard of that great land to the west? Over 50 years ago,
a sailor bound for Iceland was caught in a storm that blew him west. He came across a vast land of
ice. It could be an island. Fate has brought us here. An island covered in ice. We'll find out,
my friend. Look, be careful, it could shipwreck us. Meanwhile, on Erik's farm in Iceland,
the seasons were changing and the children were growing up. Hey, Frilla, make sure to clean the
house properly. We have to tell these slaves everything. Oh, I'm sorry. Hey, come on. He's
back. I've seen his ship. Come on, everyone. He's back. Let's go. He's here. Mom, dad's here. He's
back. I've seen his ship. Yes, mom. It's the ship of. You've returned. A huge ice shelf appeared in
front of us. We sailed south and turned around. On the other side, we discovered a lush, fertile
land with plenty of game and fish. It was incredible. A new land with plenty of food.
Listen to me. It's a country we'll call Greenland. We'll find everything we need there. It's the
land of the forgiver. I know the route. Who dares to come with me? Calling Greenland the land of the
true wasn't exactly the truth, but he was very clever and convinced them. We're on our way.
About 600 people set off with him for his green land. Ah, ah, it's a storm. No, look, there it is.
the 25 ships that had set out with Eric, only 14 reached Greenland. Ah, ah, the 400 ships would
found a new colony. Here we are. The climate was harsh, not very suitable for farming,
but there was plenty of fish and the little colony was able to survive reasonably well.
Greenland, Greenland, what does all this have to do with America, the Wild West,
cowboys and skyscrapers? Skyscrapers and cowboys, huh? We'll get to that later,
but now take a look at the map. They had already crossed three quarters of the North Atlantic.
And what about the sailor who was blown off course by the storm and discovered a new land?
His name was Birni, and he set sail from Iceland to join his father in Greenland,
but he was blown off course and ended up on a flat land covered in a large forest.
Let's go ashore. No, this does not fit the description of Greenland. There are no forests
there. We will set a course northwest. They continued sailing for a few days and eventually
landed in the southwestern part of Greenland. And it's a safe bet that Bernaral's father was there.
For 15 years, no one paid much attention to that mysterious land in the west and around the year
1000. Beneath those clouds there's a land and I'd wager it's the land that old Birni was talking
about. Yes, let's go talk to my father. We'd like to buy old Birni's ship and sail in search of the
island of the forests. If such a place exists, the wood wouldn't be of much use. There's not
enough wood in iceland anymore hem you sail well but how would you plan your route looking west
towards those mountains on clear days there are clouds on the horizon that don't appear over the
sea the only explanation is land and when you discovered greenland did you know the way this
is my son you'll take his ship and discover your new lands why don't you leave this expedition
we have to give the boys a chance i'm getting too old for this sort of thing be careful he could
outdo his old father. I don't care. I know he's in the best of hands. Please be very careful, brother.
You needn't worry, Freddy's. Next time you'll come with us. Everything will be fine. I read good
omens for you in the magic runes. May the god Odin protect you. Last time this sunstone showed us
the way. The first land Lay saw was Buffen Island, just north of the sun passes. It's not very
welcoming here, is it? Ulan, the land of the flat stones. Hey, how about we go back home? I was just
asking. Yes, this was the land we saw before we turned around and headed for Greenland. We should
keep going southeast. There they are a few days later in Labrador. That's where we were on the
trip with Bernarni. That's it. All that wood is the forest country. Let's keep going. We can always
come back later. Okay, we're going home. Not yet. Two days later, they're in the Gulf of the Saw,
Lawrence River. We have to stay in formation so we don't get lost. This land is paradise.
Imagine our animals grazing here.
It would be a good life, wouldn't it, Le?
Leaf and his men built cabins and spent the winter there.
Now that spring has come, we'll go exploring.
Go on.
What a strange animal.
It must be friendly.
Ellipsis dot.
Smells bad.
It actually stinks a bit.
Boss, I don't feel well.
My head hurts.
No, don't come any closer.
Go to the back.
Have you seen it?
They're huge.
Vineyards.
Millions of vines and grapes.
Wild grapes.
so many that we couldn't eat them all. I've only tried a couple. Discovering wild grapes
unknown in Scandinavia led Leif to call this place Vinland, the country of the vines.
Oh, as always, I can't trust anyone here. This whole story about wild grapes is false,
completely false. The word Vin means grassy land in Old Norse, so they called it Vin because it
would be a splendid place to graze animals. Come on, let's start over. Look what I found.
look, I guess I didn't find anything, but I could have sworn I did. What did I find? I don't know,
I get forgetful. Now it turns out we're leaving, but we're doing so well here. Oh, if this is
paradise, why are we leaving? Don't worry, we'll be back and many of us will stay here. By the way,
your story about the grapes could be very useful to us. Le proved himself a worthy son to his
father. When Lee's family heard that he had discovered a fertile land with a mild climate
a few days before, we all wanted to go, la. When can we leave? My father is not well. It is my duty
to look after him and watch over our lands, but Zorbal, my little brother, will go with you. Go
ahead. Ah, tack. Well, they didn't kill anyone, did they? Could have been worse. They're just a
bunch of savages. They're worthless. Yes, a bunch of arrogance. I think they've wounded me. Glory to
you, great Odin. May the Valkyries bring the noble formal to you as a hero and may he dwell
in Valjalla forever. Master, your brother-in-law, the merchant Torfinn Alfni has just arrived from
Iceland. Hey, tell him welcome to Greenland and that I'll see him now. Yes, it's wine, a luxury
we experience very rarely. That land is very rich. We could colonize it. Since my father died, I have
too many responsibilities and I couldn't leave. My brother tried, but those damned savages killed
him. Besides, it would take well-armed ships and men, women, animals. No, that's impossible now.
Torfinn has these ships well equipped and ready to set sail. A man of such high rank could lead
such an expedition. Sign on to my ship. I'm an expert hunter. As for training men to fight
those savages, I know how to train them. I have plenty of merchandise. We can use it to trade
with them, and if that doesn't work, we can resort to force. It's best if you spend the
winter here with us. In the spring, when the weather improves, we'll prepare for your journey.
Well said, brother. But let me remind you that there's always been someone from our family on
those journeys. I'll go on this one. On one condition that you be careful. Keep going. Keep
going. The first winter was very mild. The cattle found plenty of grazing land, but on the other
hand there wasn't enough food for a colony that size. Trouble began. It didn't take long for it
to erupt into open hostility. Back. She's mine. There's only one way to fix it. By losing the
patience of life. Do you understand? When spring finally came, the settlers had their first
encounter with the natives. The Indians. At first they were very pleased with all the merchandise.
We must fortify our camp and destroy them before they come here and kill us in our sleep.
Without their food we could not have survived the winter. Well, I say they are dangerous.
Yes, you are right. They are dangerous. All the bartering we have done has been advantageous to us.
I see no reason to spoil it. They are fierce savages. Do as you please. I will not stay and
have my throat cut for a night. I am no fool. So Torgal and eight of his men set sail for Greenland,
but a violent storm drove them out into the Atlantic. Finally, their ship made landfall in
Iceland. Where are they? Where are they? They are returning to trade with us. We will not be able to
do so. We have absolutely nothing left. They attack us with weapons. Call yourselves warriors
and run from mere savages. Cowards, give me a sword. I will teach you how to defeat them.
Torgal was right. There are too many of them and too few of us. There will never be peace now.
We'll have to go. And they're Vikings. What bad luck. That was the Vikings' last attempt to
colonize America. It's easy to see why their descendants are proud of them. Five centuries
before Columbus and Magellan, these giants of the north, more than anyone else of their time,
pushed the boundaries of the unknown, but they plundered and left destruction in their wake.
That's why we call them barbarians.
For three centuries, Viking society was the most dynamic and open-minded of the Middle Ages.
Merchants, warriors, pirates can be counted among the most courageous adventurers of all time.
Let's explore the corners of our ever-turning world to find routes to chart,
always taking a step further and never giving up.
More for the good of humanity.